[Musique]
n'oublions pas que à côté de l'épidémie
actuelle toutes les pathologies continue
à exister et il faut faire face les gens
continuent à voir un infarctus continue
à avoir un accident vasculaire cérébral
continue avant et pyélonéphrite continue
à tomber dans les escaliers à se
fracturer les pôles etc
enfin voilà tout existe et il ne faut
pas oublier que le médecin reste
disponible pour toutes les pathologies
[Musique]
si un cabinet est équipé pour accueillir
des patients dans ces conditions
difficiles souvent ce sont des centres
de santé des maisons médicales des
cabinets de groupe qui peuvent permettre
d'accueillir des patients qui sont peut
être infecté qui sont suspects de
transmettre la maladie donc dans ces cas
là il va y avoir un parcours des
patients infectés il y aura une salle
d'attenté reprennent préserver il y aura
un cabinet médical réservé permettant de
limiter les risques d'épidémies
téléconsultation permet de préserver
tout le monde et permet de ne pas perdre
ne pas entraîner un risque qui serait un
risque important de passer à côté de
pathologies sous jacentes pour lesquels
le patient habituellement consultent et
là il dit bah je vais rester à la maison
c'est plus prudent et et puis du coup
les signes évolué et il arrive à
consulter un petit peu plus tard et nous
ne voulons pas que ce soit trop tard